[Music]
a one on Karate school closing in the
southwest Valley the owner claiming that
the landlord wants to double his rent
and has refused to fix anything 8 news
now reporter Madison Kimbrough joins us
live tonight near Fort Apache and
Hacienda with a story you'll only see on
8 news now Madison
[Applause]
a parent reached out to us Sharon helps
that she and her family are that now
that this karate school has been 4
forced to shut down
tonight we hear from her and the owner
who claims the landlord was unfairly
evicted
I came here one day and doors were
locked
stick around the wall and locks were
changed that was Alan Sarris owner of
Las Vegas karate school that used to be
located here in the southwest Valley but
as of recent Sarah says he was evicted
for not paying his rent listen until you
fix the roof I'm not paying I will put
it in escrow or whatever I do but I need
the roof fixed then I got a eviction
notice now unless we double your rent
we're not fixing the roof we need you
out of here Sarah's claims that property
owner golden River Realty refused to fix
Necessities like the leaking roof
cracked flooring and windows Center
picture after picture this all happening
within a month's spanned and now parents
like Corinne Benbow left without a space
to take her nine-year-old daughter
Brandis who with special needs the fact
that his karate school is going to be
closing that's a that's big that's a big
shake-up in this community because where
are the kids going to go now Benbow says
her daughter has been taking karate
classes here for the past two years and
it's created a safe place for those like
her who are on the Spectrum Corinne also
believes been extremely helpful in her
daughter's development as well as giving
her the ability to speak up and defend
herself being able to give her more
self-confidence
it's also been able to help her with her
memory and that is transpired through
school
[Music]
now I was able to get in touch with
golden River Realty who denied these
allegations of not fixing certain items
they did say they were not going to
squeak to Media unless their attorney
was involved reporting live here in the
southwest Valley Madison Kimbrough 8
news now Las Vegas karate school has
been operating in the valley for 40
years Allen is looking for another
location after spending 17 years in the
southwest Valley